lisa foiles here with gamespot i get to
hang out in the nintendo booth finally
soaks i mean you can see this like giant
pikachu giant kirby but more importantly
we're about to check out some dancers
here on just dance 2015 let's check it
out all right I want to jump in and help
them but I feel like they're doing
better than I would I mean clearly all
those dance lessons my mom put me and
I'm not sure they would help here this
is more like an exercise program than it
does an actual dance class or dance
routine oh look at this
I really think that they're tricking
people into exercising right now ooh
freestyle freestyle they're spinning
this is very entertaining firm huh
splatoon runner here giant giant
presence I was told it was called
spittoon so I'm now feeling stupid that
it's called splatoon basically it's like
a paintball game but man these guys are
still going strong look at look at east
move he's just running into people as
they walk God Allah gotta love the
dancing presence at every III there's
usually like a big stage setup but you
know this is just as good here Oh
try it try these in the club ladies and
gentlemen
I might have to jump in probably not
though I don't know that's not not sure
that's real dancing but i like it i'm
foreign smash brothers behind you as you
can see people are stoked stoked about
the smash brothers you know I've never
been good at it but oh that's just a
button screen so there you go let's see
let's come Rani oh it's watching people
play whoa I almost got caught up in the
in the just dancing look at this I'm
loving this okay all right let's check
out some smash brother Inge all right
man I so wish I was good at smash
brothers it's like the perfect party
game but I've always been tamed that at
mario party those like the two games
here like not allowed to play with
friends because it just destroys
friendship but uh no no let's see if
this let's just crash the boat like we
usually do huh hey hey hi I'm filming
you have you played yet yes ma'am wait I
will you play I played a lot what's your
favorite new level uh you know there's a
lot of new features but they're all
great they all look great there's a lot
of new characters which is awesome but
right now we're featuring smash run it's
a five-minute maze they'll run through
to gather as many power-ups as they can
this guy's gonna demo it for you right
now we had to see it hopefully we have
time we're gonna check it out that's
very different I might actually be good
at that at like some kind of running a
race instead of just pounding on one
another I don't know if we're gonna
we're not gonna have talked but you know
what we'll check it out we'll check it
out later but yeah here you go Nintendo
we're gonna check out more self in a
tattoo I want to head over there but
tweet me tell me what you want to see
hashtag is 23 see you then